Who loves mark Wahlberg?
I do. Right?
(audience applauds)
Well, Mark is about to hit-
Me, me, me, me, me, me.
Drew loves him.
He's about to hit the big screen again
in a movie called "Father Stu",
which is an inspirational story about a Catholic priest.
And this has been a passion project for Mark,
and now Entertainment Tonight reports
Mark transformed himself for the movie.
He gained 30 pounds in six weeks, you guys.
Oh, I could do that.
Yeah, I'm like, uh, how do you do it?
By going to lunch with Drew and I, that's how he did it.
We can do that.
(audience laughs)
But no, here's really how he did it.
He worked up an appetite by lifting weights in the morning.
Oh, I don't do that.
I don't do that either.
And then this is what he ate.
He built up on a dozen eggs,
a dozen strips of bacon.
That's a lot.
Two baked potatoes,
a steak,
two bowls of white rice
and a full glass of olive oil.
(audience gasps in disgust)
Blergh.
If they came to you though, and said
"Here's a great part, it's the part of a lifetime
but you have to put on 30 pounds",
are you in?
I mean, I can do that so easily.
(audience laughs)
That is like,
that is not a big deal for me.
I've had two kids and I'm 47, so that's,
(audience applauds)
30 pounds
is not a challenge.
I'm like a Shar-Pei, that pouch fills up real fast.
(audience laughs)
Yeah, (laughs) Shar-Pei.
Well, everything sounded so good that he ate,
except for that big glass of olive oil,
Drinking a glass of olive oil?
I could not, don't, don't tell me you're gonna, oh God.
No.
(audience groans)
Oh my God.
(audience gasps)
I can't even think about it.
Drink, drink, drink, drink, drink.
Are you nuts?
Are you gonna drink some?
(audience claps and chants)
Oh God.
(audience screams and cheers)
Blech.
It's so groaty.
I can't do it.
I can't do...
Oh my God.
That is, that is,
that's the grossest thing we've had at the desk.
But I will say,
I love Mark Wahlberg so much.
Me too.
Mm-hm.
(audience applauds)
Beyond.
All right, next, a wedding conundrum.
This comes to us from USA Today's advice column.
A soon to be bride writes that she and her fiance
are planning an October wedding,
because they wanted to do it in the Halloween style.
They're both gonna wear black,
but it turns out the bride's mom, not pleased.
Her father just wants her to be happy
but her mom is an old school, traditional Catholic
and is basically saying,
"I don't know if I can come to this wedding
if you do it this way, I might have to boycott
if you wear the black wedding dress
that you're planning on".
And so the bride is asking, is she wrong?
Oh, I'll tell you right now.
The mom is wrong.
You're wrong.
It's not your wedding.
(audience applauds)
Do you have children so that they can just live your life?
No, you have them so they can live their life.
So if she wants a freaky Halloween wedding,
trick or treat honey, let her have it.
(audience applauds and cheers)
I actually would like to say to the mom,
I, maybe we let our daughters pull a 4-92 and just be free.
Oh.
And do their own thing.
(audience applauds)
And I just also wanna say to the mom
that I don't just mean that as a pithy metaphor.
So this costume is on order right now,
because this is what my daughter
wants to wear to her birthday.
And if you'll look, here is the invitation
that she designed for her birthday.
(audience reacts)
Oh my gosh.
So I had to have debates with Frankie about what level
of fear I was going to instill in other parents.
So 4-92?
C'est la vie.
(audience applauds)
(bright music)